thèse voilà plus de deux mois que l'on
découvrait ligoté et noyer et le corps
du petit grégory dans une rivière près
d'epinal son oncle bernard laroche est
toujours en prison sous le coup d'une
inculpation qui ne repose plus que sur
les témoignages de ses nièces puisque
vous le savez le tribunal de nancy a
annulé pour vice de forme les expertises
graphologiques et il est maintenant
question de déclarer irrecevable l'un
des témoignages qui reste versés au
dossier
paul certains disent la précipitation
avec laquelle l'enquète a démarré sur la
piste bernard laroche risques dans les
jours qui viennent de déboucher sur un
conflit aigu entre le juge d'instruction
et la défense en effet au fur et à
mesure que les trois avocats de
l'inculpé le bâtonnier stasi m prouvait
l'air prenne connaissance du dossier il
constate un certain nombre
d'irrégularités de procédure dont
l'addition finalement les incite à
mettre en doute l'impartialité de
l'enquète après l'annulation par la
chambre d'accusation de nancy expertise
graphologique et l'expertisé
d'enregistrements téléphoniques
ce sont maintenant deux pièces
importantes du dossier qui apparaissent
entachée de nullité le procès verbal de
la garde à vue les gendarmes de la
petite muriel celle qui accuse bien à la
roche et le procès verbal du transfert
sur les lieux de 5 novembre dernier le
greffier n'était pas là pour noter comme
le garantit la loi le détail précis des
déclarations de l'enfant c'est important
à cela s'ajoute le fait que sur les 80
spécimens d'écriture confiée aux experts
graphologues pour comparaison avec
l'écriture de la lettre anonyme
annonçant l'assassinât de grégory 40 de
ses 80 spécimens étaient des papiers de
bernard laroche ce qui en quelque sorte
lui donner une chance sur deux d'être
désigné au stade actuel de l'instruction
seul le juge et le procureur peuvent
obtenir l'annulation c'est à dire
reconnaître qu'ils se sont trompés ou
bien qu'ils sont allés trop vite bon il
l'accepté pas sûr ou en tout cas pas
facilement mais on est bien obligé de
constater que dans cette affaire
dramatique s'ajoute à l'incertitude de
la culpabilité le doute sur la
régularité de l'accusation